we live in a world where we almost lose
control of all of our time
every day we have arrows that i call
them arrows that come at us hey
jesse can you spend 15 minutes with this
guy he wants to pick your brain on
coconut water and hey can you pay this
guy this guy wants to borrow 50
and this email needs to be written like
constantly dodging all this stuff
and we feel obligated to say yes because
we don't want to feel you know let
anyone down
and we lose control of our time how
could you be productive
have a vibrant life be successful
if someone else controls all your time
or you're filled with clutter so i did a
very simple thing
we can all do it i drew a pie chart okay
i said there's 24 hours in the day i
sleep seven of them
that leaves 17 hours in the day i take
three of them for me and those three
hours could do anything that i want
i could be i'm going for a run a steam
i'm doing nothing
i'm doing my emails i'm reading but i
don't want to resent my wife
i don't want to resent my boss i don't
resent my partner for taking away the
things
in my life that i love to do
by controlling my time three hours for
me
the average american works a 40 hour
work week that's eight hours a day
seven for sleep three for yourself eight
for work guess what
you got six hours left in the day all
the clutter is gone
now of course you have to commute you
have dinner you have family you have
meals
the point is you can be incredibly
productive incredibly creative and
credibly free
when you take control of your time when
you figure out how you want to attack
your time over the course of a week i
believe that most human beings
are only living at about 40 percent of
their capability
so the mine has a governor like a car
if you're driving a car and the car has
a governor on it
the car may say 130 miles an hour but
the governor's set for 91.
once that governor sets in you get to 91
that car starts doing this
the car wants to go the car wants to go
but that
factory said uh-uh we're not going past
91.
we have a factory a nice governor in our
brain
and it's a survival mechanism it
protects us from
pain and suffering the second we feel
that our mind says oh no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable
and there's something about the mind the
mind has the tactical advantage over you
at all times at all times of your life
the mind has a tactical advantage over
you why is that
it knows what you're afraid of it knows
your insecurities it knows your deep
dark lies
and it starts to push you away from that
it pushes you in a direction that is
comfortable
the mind controls everything so what i
realized was that when i was growing up
and i was 300 pounds and i got all fat
and i got all insecure
i realized that my mind kept taking me
in this direction when things got
uncomfortable for me when i was facing
my insecurities i was facing my fears
my mind said oh no we have the tactical
advantage we just
get you separate you from this feeling
this feeling over your life's all about
feelings
we want the happy feeling we don't want
that feeling of this
sucks why am i here and you don't have
any
so you can't answer those questions so
you leave i started realizing that
if in that moment you can answer those
questions
and you are now in charge of your brain
versus your brain ruling you
that's where all that stuff comes from
so so the 40
rule is all of that you get to 40 your
brain says
we're done let's roll man this is
starting to get painful this is
uncomfortable
so you sit down you have to figure out
ways and everybody's different that's
how the book kind of talks about
like we all have these things about you
know five steps to this
and four steps to this it's a lot more
than that
it's a practice that you have to it's a
habit so
if you know that at 40 i'm still you
know i'm feeling pain
at 40 i'm feeling pain that's where the
40 rule kicks in
now it starts okay i'm feeling pain my
mind's saying
all this to me is saying get out of here
run
flee the fight or flight kicks in okay
we're done we're not good enough
it starts telling you all these things
you start to believe it because the mind
controls all
this is the time where you have to gain
control back of your mind
it's okay let me see if i can go 45
and once you start giving yourself more
and more hope and start realizing okay
the mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left you start then
controlling your mind
start finding more in you know in
yourself and it goes from 40
to a lot further than that but that's
the start of it though get to
get to the spot where your mind is
saying stop
wherever that is you gotta get there
first and then that's when that
starts to work for you you gotta control
yourself in that moment
the thing about self-discipline is that
it is necessary
for everything you do in your life you
have to be
self-disciplined if discipline comes
from somewhere else
it's very very hard to remain consistent
because you tend to resist
it's why because i see trainers and
they're in the gym with people and
you know the guy or girl that they're
working out
hates their workout hates it because
the discipline is coming from somewhere
else you it's something that you dread
every time you go in
you don't really want to do it it's like
uh but oh no
my trainer's here he's about to you know
beat me up and make me feel crazy
well the truth is every trainer
should work his way out of your life
anybody who's working you out your
teachers your trainers your people
they have to train you to get out of
your life
so you can go ahead do your own
workout do your own thing practice
self-discipline
now one thing i want to straighten out
big time
discipline is not punishment it's not
discipline is training that's all it is
i was talking to my son one time and i
asked him and
it was weird because i was trying to see
if he really knew what it was all about
and i said hey man you know i have to
discipline you what is discipline
he goes punishment punishment when i do
something wrong and you punish me i was
like no
no discipline is training
if you change your mind your mindset
and really focus it on what discipline
really is
you start to welcome discipline you
welcome
self-discipline into your life before
you can be a painter who can
paint what's beyond mere memory
you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and
a lot of that is painful repetition
and hard grinding work it's the
sacrifice of the present for the future
but once you manage that then things
open up and
virtually everything you learn of value
is like that's very
very very difficult to learn to write
and there's arbitrary
arbitrary rules that you have to follow
and bind yourself to
and while you're learning those rules
the probability that you have any
creative freedom to speak of
or any facility with the rules is very
low you're a rank
beginner and and even to some degree
whatever creativity you have is going to
have to be stifled
while you're passing through that that
keyhole
but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side
and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions
universities are exactly that is their
places of guidance
and and they're places to encourage
people to develop the discipline that's
necessary to see
beyond the discipline i mean that's why
we have disciplines
right i mean the words aren't there by
accident you have to narrow yourself
first and then you can broaden outward
and so that's
and that's part of the process of
maturation that part of the
that's part of the sacrifice of
childhood say
in childhood you're nothing but
potential but it's not realized and you
don't know how to realize it
and so then the question is well how do
you get to a point where you realize the
potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single direction
this is nietzsche's commentary on the
catholic church he's a great admirer of
the catholic church despite the fact
that he was also a radical
critic a critic of christianity said the
cat
see the thing about the catholic church
is that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework
and that was a discipline and once that
discipline was established then
the disciplined mind could explode in
every direction which is precisely what
happened
and that's the thing about growing up is
that when you're a teenager
and a young adult you have to sacrifice
everything you could have been as a
child
to be the one thing that you're aiming
at but then that opens up and
and the universities are part and parcel
of that process and you need the
guidance because
the library is too large to wander
through it unaided
there really are only two macro level
motivators that we have in life and
that's pleasure and pain
what i want people to understand is okay
so if nature only gave you
two things to motivate you pleasure and
pain
why would you eliminate half of them and
so most people think that life is about
avoiding the pain i'm here to tell you
right now in a very controlled fashion
it is about really experiencing the pain
learning from it so ray dalio the most
successful hedge fund manager of all
time
has a perfect math equation pain plus
reflection
equals progress if you don't feel the
pain you never reflect on it
so my thing is i spend 80 of my time
focused on the beautiful things in my
life the things i'm grateful for the
beautiful things that i want to bring
into existence all of it
20 of the time though i'm in the
darkness man i'm in that tim grover
relentless
i'm going to make this happen if i have
to break myself and i'm not afraid to
lean into that because i know how
powerful it is now if you really want to
put numbers how powerful
this is they did a study and they wanted
to find out what happens how can we
get people to endure more pain and the
punchline is hilarious
so they would take people and they would
submerge their arm in a bucket of ice
and they would just
hold it there as long as you can now at
first it's just cold but after a while
it really starts to hurt
and so people would end up yanking their
arms out they found that people could
hold
their arm in the bucket 35 percent
longer
if you let them display anger so put it
in they get to that point where they're
about to pull it out and you tell them
yell cuss do whatever you need to and
they'd be able to do it
they're the expression of intensity even
what i'm doing right now i can feel
myself
ready right i'm ready to strike my
muscles are tense i've got a different
posture
i bring my chin down there's intensity
in my eyes like dude
i'm now feeling that because i'm
embodying it right
so it makes me really feel that and so i
actually started to tell the story
earlier i hate the gym
but what i would do to make myself work
out is i would my wife would be on the
opposite side of the gym and i would
stare at her and i would imagine her
being attacked
and i would imagine her being attacked
by people bigger than me and that the
only way that i could fight them off is
to get stronger
there was nothing beautiful in it i was
not worried about aesthetics i was
worried about
saving my wife and by stepping into that
dark place and because people were like
what are you doing
yeah but dude that was i needed that
motivation to push past what i want to
push past pain
boredom all of it and just to really get
into it and get a result
but i find that people shy away from
that look to me it's an 80 20 split if
you're spending more than 20
of your time there it will be corrosive
yes it will start to erode your sense of
self
because you're going to feel badly right
because i would be saying to myself
you're weak come on like you've got to
get stronger
if you spend 80 percent of your time
doing that that sucks
yes i don't want to live like that right
but not being able to dip into both
you'll just never hit the level of
extraordinary you may be fine you may
even be good yep but you're never going
to be great if you want to know how to
develop discipline like eric thomas
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you know if it was easy everybody
could do it if it was
a cookie cutter everybody would just
follow it to the t but there's a mindset
and when i looked at serena
you know when i look at the michael
jordan